il y a environ 48 minutes, votre président
a déclaré la guerre à l'ukraine,
alors maintenant, je voudrais demander à l'
ambassadeur de la fédération de russie de
dire publiquement
qu'en ce moment même
vos troupes ne bombardent pas les
villes ukrainiennes
dans lesquelles vos troupes ne se déplacent pas  le
territoire de l'ukraine
vous avez un smartphone vous pouvez appeler
lavrov en ce moment car il est trop tard
mes chers collègues pour parler de l'
escalade trop tard
le président russe a déclaré la guerre
sur le dossier dois je passer la vidéo de
votre président
ambassadeur dois je faire ça  en ce moment ou
vous ne pouvez pas le confirmer alors j'appelle chacun
d'entre vous
à faire tout son possible pour arrêter la
guerre